smoke rising through the air and paper
scattered across the ground as far as
the eye can see
this video shot by our residents shows
the aftermath of an explosion at an
apartment building in chernikev ukraine
on march 3rd at least 47 people died in
russian bombings in this city that day
many other strikes have directly hit
civilians
schools houses and evacuation routes in
the country have been attacked and
severely damaged
on top of infrastructure including this
children's hospital
[Music]
russia has denied targeting civilians
but our reporting in ukraine and videos
show that in fact civilians have been
badly hit
journal reporters and the news
intelligence agency story full
corroborated dozens of video clips
shared by ukrainian officials and
residents
analysis of those videos shows that
despite the kremlin's denials russian
forces have been hitting civilians
across ukraine as resistance slowed
their military advances
chernihiv is a city in northern ukraine
home to more than 280 thousand people a
strategic location northeast of kyiv and
near the border with belarus has led to
a heavy presence of russian forces in
the area
near the building seen in this footage
there's a hospital a hotel shops but no
sign of ukrainian military presence or
facilities apart from a checkpoint
manned by a few volunteers according to
residents
in that neighborhood a dashcam recording
posted to social media shows the
powerful explosion
footage shows a children's playground
after the blast as well as the remains
of a pharmacy which google earth images
show previously looked like this there's
a place you'd you know go shopping and
take your kids to uh to go and play in
the playground a little bit it's a it's
a very
quiet pleasant residential area
the woman who shot this video who is
also a journalist told the wall street
journal that she was shopping when the
attack happened
she rushed home where her son was with
his grandmother her son and his
grandmother survived but you see you
know that they're now in a difficult
situation no gas no electricity
everything smashed up uh
terrible destruction
the family managed to flee a few days
after the attack
but in many cities under siege residents
say they've been trapped and are
struggling to survive
in the southern city of mariopol there
were scenes of desperation as dead
bodies could be seen uncollected on the
streets
[Music]
ukraine and russia said more than once
that they had agreed on some logistics
for humanitarian corridors to let
residents flee some cities including
mariopol but efforts were complicated by
continued fighting
on march 9 president vladimir zelinsky
was one of several ukrainian officials
to share videos showing a severely
damaged children's hospital
russia's foreign minister said the
hospital was being used as a base by
ukrainian fighters a claim denied by the
city's mayor
those trying to leave have also faced
attacks according to the mayor of urpin
at least eight civilians were killed by
shelling during an evacuation attempt in
this suburb of kiev
scenes of destruction resemble each
other across ukraine
in jatomir which is located west of kiev
video shows a school building reduced
mostly to rubble on march 4th the
footage was circulated on a telegram
channel about war videos
there's something of a strange target
for the russians in the sense that it
doesn't lie on the front lines and in
kharkiv ukraine's second largest city
large-scale destruction of residential
and historical buildings was documented
for several days in a row
after russian forces failed to capture
major urban centers
what the locals say is that this simply
looks like a way to try to terrify them
to frighten them
by indiscriminate bombing
russian president vladimir putin has
denied that moscow is targeting
civilians on march 7 in a phone call
with a european official putin said his
forces were taking steps to save
civilian lives by offering escape
corridors for residents
he also accused keeve of obstructing
those efforts according to the kremlin's
account of the phone call
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
has repeatedly denounced the attacks
in early march the international
criminal court opened an investigation
into possible war crimes in ukraine
with bombs and missiles pounding cities
across the country the united nations
said hundreds of civilians had died many
more had been wounded and millions had
fled contributing to the worst
humanitarian crisis in europe since
world war ii